ياتي يومنا المكون من 24 ساعه من قدماء
المصريين الذين قسموا وقت النهار الى عشر
ساعات قاموا بقياسها بساعات الظل وتم
تقسيم الليل الى 12 ساعه بناء على ملاحظات
النجوم وكان طول ساعات النهار والليل غير
متساوي ومتنوع باختلاف الفصول وفي عصر
الدوله الحديثه تم تبسيط النظام باستخدام
مجموعه من اربع وعشرين النجمه 12 من هذه
النجمه تمثل مرور فتره الليل والباقي مثل
مرور النهار اما التقسيم الفرعي للساعات
والدقائق الى 60 ياتي من البابلي القدماء
الذين وضعوا دائره وقسموها الى 360 جزءا
واختاروا هذا الرقم نسبه لعدد ايام السنه
وتم اتباع النظام السداسي لتقسيم الوقت
لتسهيل عمليه تقسيم الدائره الاربعه
وانصاف كانت هناك محاولات بعد ثوره
الفرنسيه لتقسيم الوقت بطريقه مختلفه
وتطبيق نظام 20 يقسم عدد دقائق والثاني
الى مئه وحده بدل من 60 وحده لكن لي سهل
ان تقنع العالم كله بتغيير نظام كما تبنيه
منذ قرون بالاضافه الى التعقيدات
الاقتصاديه والتكنولوجيا التي قد يوجهها
امر كهذا